entre les murs de l'édifice de l' agence
du revenu du canada ou centre-ville de
montréal sont conservés les informations
les plus confidentielles qui soient nos
salaires nos transactions nos
investissements nos mariages et même nos
divorces lorsqu'il est question de
l'infiltration de la mafia au sein de
cette institution
les conséquences peuvent être très
graves il y a deux ans nous avions
révélé l'existence d'une enquête sur la
corruption à l' agence du revenu du
canada avec ce témoignage choc d'un
vérificateur qui voulaient rester
anonyme
moi je vous dirais que depuis au moins
au moins 20 ans
souvent les vérificateurs on a été
témoin d'actes qui laisse croire
qu'effectivement il ya de la corruption
au sein de l'agencé du revenu
ce que vous nous dites pendant les
années la direction s'est fermé les yeux
ou a été très tolérants très tolérante
j'irai plus tolérante que fermer les
yeux
aujourd'hui devant la gravité de la
situation notre témoin a décidé de ne
plus cacher
[Musique]
jean pierre paquette avait été à
l'origine de l'enquêtre sur la
corruption à lagence avec des
révélations qui avait entraîné une vague
de congédiements mêmes d'arrestations
pourquoi aujourd'hui accepte de vous
dévoiler juin euros cette enquête donc à
ce moment là c'était 10 10 cordes des
voix dès mardi danse
aujourd'hui les accusations sont portées
le dossier ça en vallée de la vère savon
et l'autre raison aux courbes et en plus
c'est des coupures qui viennent de se
refaire dans la section ski a été coupée
c'est le programme spécial d'exécution
le pse est spécialisée dans la lutte
contre le crime organisé et qui
travaillaient presque en symbiose avec
la grc un groupe de vérificateurs
chevronnés qui faisait trembler les
criminels cette coupure a été fait dans
la réorganisation de l'agencé dans la
foulée des compressions budgétaires du
gouvernement harper jean pierre paquette
a consacré toute sa vie professionnelle
au psg avant de prendre sa retraite en
2009 d'expériences et d'expertisés
exactement donc le fonds d'éducation
donc un nouveau retraité
et oui je suis passée votre première
journée de pensionnés jusqu'il ya deux
semaines robert martin était aussi un
membre du pse il en a vu de toutes les
couleurs
en 25 ans en quête sur le crime organisé
il a même été menacé et avait vu une
voiture de type mauvais mot était une
offense aux matons peu maudit bon ben ça
et possède aussi les gens du pse aime à
dire qu'ils formaient un groupe à part
au sein de l' agence plus que de simples
fonctionnaires assis à leur bureau ils
se considèrent comme des justiciers
ayant à coeur de s'attaquer aux
criminels et plus riches
guy daigneault était aussi enquêteurs au
pse la meilleure façon d'attaquer
système s'auto d'adp essayer de
l'arracher de large
la meilleure façon comme vous savez
c'est l'impôt la même stratégie gagnante
que les américains utilisés contre ak
pong au siècle dernier on nous donnait
des sauts bosses et elle y est née à
travailler continuer de l'homme les
policiers le ps n'était jamais très loin
de la mafia qui daignent on a même eu la
surprise de recevoir à son bureau un des
plus hauts dirigeants de la mafia de
montréal est venu voir le vérificateur
qui travaillent en a dans l'équipe
et puis j'ai été très surpris de le
rencontrer seul allah seul dans votre
bureau croyable un grand show incroyable
je ne sois pas le droit avait des
milliers penser qu'ils couraient après
qu'il connaissait puis est venu nous
voir directement je n'existe prochain
j'ai pas que ça existe possède le pse a
été mis sur pied dans la foulée des
travaux de la seco dans les années 80
lors d'une enquête sur la fraude fiscale
d'un secteur du textile à montréal
coopté - provenait du monde participer
info collectif pour payer deux ou
fonctionnaires de l' agence du revenu
prévenu fed donald kohn pour un montant
d'un million seller d'une enquête dans
des manufactures qu'on a vu deux
premiers indices de corruption au sein
de revenu canada cette perquisition
après perquisition dans un an différents
commerces ou est-ce qu'on nous attend
d'être une terre les boîtes étaient de
joie pour être sûr d'avoir d'abord pizza
ou pas par le chanteur keith urban et
document sonore que visuel tout ça n'a
pas été concluant
il ya eu des arrangements nos bidons se
sont fait hors de ces corporations et
l'eau et est revenu canada
ces arrangements comme le dit
jean-pierre paquette avait attiré
l'attention de fernand côté qui était à
l'époque le procureur en chef de la seco
son enquête a permis de débusquer une
autre arnaque on avait découvert l'un
des cartons l'algérie on se transporte
et manteaux de fourrure 2 millions en
argent il fit des fonds avaient retrouvé
le plus grave dans cette histoire selon
m côté c'est ce qui s'est passé après la
perquisition
des propriétaires de maisons de ces
entreprises là s'étaient rendus à ottawa
en compagnie du receveur corps aurait
aurait dû bien dénoncer le pdg de des
ventes ou noir camouflé de l'ordre d'un
million auraient offert de payer
d'impôts pour un million mais pour
l'auto millions il y aurait pas eu de
charges sociales mais l'avocat côté ne
sentait pas beaucoup de volonté des
autorités pour aller au fond des choses
nous avons recommandé le visa malgré les
procureurs de la couronne se penche sur
le dossier et voir s'il y avait des
poursuites judiciaires intentées à ma
connaissance jamais eu de poursuites
intentées le rapport sur cet événement
il restait caché depuis toutes ces
années aux archives nationales du québec
c'est le seul rapport de l'has écho à
notre connaissance qui n'a pas été rendu
public
après la ccal ps s est attaqué à la
mafia mais déjà au bureau de l'agencé à
montréal des informations circulaient
sur un groupe de fonctionnaires
corrompus l'an 88 sasp à 80,88 oui
plupart voire des pommes politique les
vérificateurs du pse ont toujours
travaillé en étroite collaboration avec
la grc sur les dossiers de la mafia jean
pierre paquette a participé à l'enquêté
antimafia colisée au début des années
2000 c'est comme ça qu'il est tombé en
2006 sur une information capitale qu'est
la faire éclater le scandale sur la
corruption à l' agence du revenu du
canada
tout a commencé par une lettre anonyme
qui a conduit l'agencé la grc sur la
piste du fameux stratagème de fausse
facturation impliquant les entreprises
françaises comme bruno et de tony
accurso
les informations contenues dans la
fameuse lettre ont eu des conséquences
majeures
six employés de l'agencé font face
actuellement à des accusations
criminelles pour corruption
les hommes d'affaires francesco bruno et
tony accurso ont été arrêtés l'an
dernier et font face à des accusations
de fraude et d'abus de confiance
il risque la prison il est allégué que
francesco bruno de bt céramique qui a
des liens avec la mafia dont le clan
rizzuto aurait joué un rôle central dans
cette histoire de corruption
pendant des années il a tissé patiemment
des liens avec des employés de lagence
en commençant par son cousin adriano
furgiuele qui lui aussi a été arrêté et
qui était chef d'equipe pour la
vérification des petites et moyennes
entreprises
il aurait été au coeur du stratagème de
fausse facturation de bruno il aurait
même aidé à transférer une somme de près
de 2 millions dans des paradis fiscaux
la grc affirme que four duels et est à
l'origine de ce plan intitulé plan novak
chaîne qui a permis à accurso et bruno
d'éluder des millions en impôts selon
des documents de perquisitions bruno
aurait même entretenu des liens dans la
haute direction de l'agent ce soit avec
madame qui a un homme qui jouait des
millions dans des casinos
la grc laisse entendre qu'il fréquentait
bruno dans des casinos ce que quai à nie
fermement
madan kehar aujourd'hui à la retraite ne
fait face à aucune accusation
toujours selon la grc bruno n'hésitez
pas non plus à payer des repas bien
arrosé à ses amis vérificateur nom de
chic restaurant de montréal
il est allé jusqu'à les invités dans une
loge au centre bell encore là toutes
dépenses payées en fait d' enquête de la
grc sur la corruption à lagence a pris
forme autour du cas de bruno
mais les choses n'ont pas été faciles on
aurait même tenté d'étouffer la faire
vous dites donc y avait des pressions
pour ne pas faire grand chose c'est un
abri donc pendant un an on prenait plus
jouer aux us et veilleux à l'agent
revenus cette information là je peux
pour vous d'organisation parle de
certains individus en particulier qui
vous a mis les bâtons verrous ça me met
des bâtons des pas vraiment le temps de
s'occuper ces informations leur
préfèrent d'autres choses nombreux
procès à autre chose
jusqu'au jour et manger j'ai rencontré
ou du jeun ma devise du côté des pros
mais parce que moi j'ai de la preuve
comme quoi canada corruption il a percé
d'un homme un nom ça a tranché
en plus cette enquête s'est déroulée
dans un climat explosif avec de
nombreuses tentatives d'intimidation
tellement que certains dirigeants de l'
agence ont dû avoir recours à des gardes
du corps un d'entre eux a même été
tabassé à la sortie d'un party de bureau
en 2011 corruption menaces intimidations
et tabassages
un cocktail qui fait penser à la mafia
est il possible que ce que le ps
combattait ne soit parvenu à avoir leur
entrée au coeur même de l' agence du
revenu
novembre 2006
l'arrestation du parrain de la mafia
montréal nicolo rizzuto
aux termes de l' enquête colisée dirigé
par la grc
c'est la plus grosse rappelé antimafia
de l'histoire du canada soixante dix
personnes liées à la mafia sont arrêtés
dans l'enquêté colisée on s'était rendu
compte de la mafia avait étendu ses
tentacules partout
elle avait invité l'aéroport pierre
elliott trudeau pour faciliter
l'importation de stupéfiants au pays
mais encore plus grave
nous possédons des indices sérieux
laissant croire à l'infiltration des
plus hauts dirigeants de la mafia au
sein de l' agence du revenu du canada
alors j'aimerais vous montrer un chèque
que c'est un chèque à l'ordre de nicolo
rizzuto le parrain oui combien trois ans
1,80 m indoor ce chèque de remboursement
est daté du 13 septembre 2007 adressé à
nul autre que nicolo rizzuto le parrain
de la mafia assassiné trois ans plus
tard
à cette époque il était en prison à ce
moment leurs résultats devaient un
million et demi de dollars au fisc
fédéral
c'est jean pierre paquette qui s'est
rendu compte de la méprise dans les
jours suivant la réception du chèque
sous pression la famille rizzuto accepté
de rendre le chèque au gouvernement et
c'est jean pierre paquet lui-même qui
est allé chercher à la résidence de
nicolo rizzuto
en ce jour nous ferons venir
mais par la suite le jeu des filtres oui
il s'apprend désapprobation tout au long
du processus passe est plus probable que
soit une ration
si on regarde ça de cet oeil là je me
pose de sérieuses questions
jean pierre paquette est d'autant plus
sceptiques qu'à la même époque l' agence
du revenu du canada avait obtenu une
hypothèque légale sur des pieds de
nicolo rizzuto pour qui pèse 1 million
et demi qui devait au fisc
car c'est que le compte de monsieur le
tour d'après moi l'eau n'était pas
entièrement pays au moment de l'émission
de chèques l'eau ça me laisse très
perplexe sur la validité d'un tel
remboursement ou d'une telle opération
d'apport d'argent
robert martin ne comprend pas non plus
comment l'agent aurait pu émettre un tel
chez runiso là ça ne se prend quelqu'un
parce que nos mamans trend est chez nous
mais ce tombeau s'amender impossible à
prononcer sur les appels et françois
aussi pourquoi il ya un privilège
robert martin sait comment il est facile
de corrompre vérificateur lui même a été
la cible d'une tentative de corruption
par une famille proche de la mafia en
2002 leur compagnie construction avait
caché 12 millions à l'impôt
plus vite la famille dans le bureau du
comptable m'approcher du moma demander
carrément bon écoute tout on y prête à
te donner mon temps cent mille de
l'homme puis toi diminuer les
cotisations mais le patient proposition
mauvaise personne ne pouvait me faire
acheter aux 100000 monsieur martin ne
veut pas dévoiler l'identité des gens
qui ont voulu le corrompre pour des
raisons de sécurité mais des documents
de cour confirme cette tentative de
corruption dans ces documents il est
question de la tenue éventuelle d'une
enquête criminelle de la grc mais qui
n'a jamais eu lieu
mais toutes ces histoires de corruption
à lagence de retenue ne serait que la
pointe de l'iceberg d'une situation
beaucoup plus grave
des sources internes nous ont révélé
l'existence d'une filière plus
importante que celle démanteler que les
sommes en cause aurait dépassé les
dizaines de millions de dollars selon
ces sources
le stratagème s'articulait autour du
gonflement par des vérificateurs
corrompus des réclamations d'impôt exigé
à des entreprises dans un premier temps
ses vérificateurs informait d'anciens
collègues devenus consultants des
montants réclamés
par la suite les consultants avec la
complicité des mêmes vérificateur véreux
offrait à ses entreprises de réduire
leurs réclamations d'impôts moyennant
une importante commission
il était facile pour ces consultants de
faire réduire le montant
puisque la réclamation était gonflé
artificiellement et qu'ils étaient de
connivence avec leur ex collègue
consultant et vérificateurs n'avaient
plus par la suite qu'elle se partager la
commission au delà de ce stratagème nos
témoins affirment que les agissements de
certains anciens vérificateurs et cadres
devenu consultant à fiscalité mais la
réputation de lagence surtout lorsqu'ils
représentent des individus sans scrupule
perdu générale des aînés aux dirigeants
qui sont épiés dans un dossier incident
chaalis de lagence prennent leur
retraite mais un mois plus tard son nom
du conseiller juridique ou conseillés
tout le no 6 dans lesquelles il était
dans l'eau child fait qu'ils apprennent
radio et de plus que respect de tupi je
trouve
soyons ce conflit d'intérêts total total
jour dans mes veines la retraite qui a
travaillé rosberg mais jusqu'à quel
point d'être était assez sale et en
chine où est-ce que vous avez vu
plusieurs comme ça ni vu quelques-uns
des cadres dk druide et oui j'ai eu des
cadres qui ont été représentant le chef
des chefs d'equipe directeur de mesure
où donc jour au lendemain se retrouve
chez d g la présente qu'il représente
les des gens de 2 km organisée
dans ce contexte pourquoi couper le
programme spécial d'exécution le pse une
véritable escouade mi temps contre la
corruption et le crime organisé
l' agence du revenu a refusé toute
entrevue à la caméra pour répondre à nos
questions notamment sur le chèque à
nicolo rizzuto sur la disparition du ps
la direction souligne dans une
communication écrite qu'il n'y a pas eu
de diminution des ressources consacrées
à la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale que
son mandat n'a pas été abandonnée que
ces ressources ont été réaffectés
ailleurs mais robert martin est
sceptique
lui qui travaillait sur le plus gros
dossier de blanchiment d'argent de sa
carrière dégoûté il a décidé
d'abandonner son enquête et de prendre
sa retraite prématurément et vous vous
êtes sorti ces jours ci en grande partie
à cause de la disparition du ps
exact je suis triste de savoir que c'est
un genre de dossier là ce principe a pu
vérifier ça me frustre de voir que les
gens vont aller est large les seconds
peu folle et systèmes ce que
l'expression mais maintenant que des
chefs d'equipe sont encore laure est
corrompue où ils y ont toutefois appelé
lily liste orly doit aussi y prend goût
nous y mettre un tiroir et à aucune
logique là dedans je comprends pas mais
jamais jamais cru charest peut parler du
ps au passé j'ai consacré ma vie
elle s'acharne une petite coiffeuse il
est le produit 1000 de l'ordre de
pourboire par annie puis que l'autre
personne blanchir 7,8 millions on
touchera pas au sol
non ça va l'incompréhension des anciens
vérificateurs est d'autant plus grande
que leur groupe qui avait collaboré avec
la grc dans l' enquête colisée a
remporté en 2008 le prix d'excellence de
toute la fonction publique fédérale
on était nominé et on a reçu dans
l'avion si on donne à l'eau on vient
nous dire que en fin de compte notre
travail t'as pas important la section
disparaît puis c'est pas des excuses
mais bon pourquoi que toutes les
employées de l'argent à ses deux moteurs
rompu au contraire c'est tout le monde
qui prennent ces écarts mais une petite
minorité une optique sans minorité fait
mal à la majorité des employés de moi
qu'est ce qui m'encourage en dessous
c'est que revenu québec et dans une
quand la ville est depuis
nous sautons pas beaucoup de plumes je
pense qu'on est venu expliquer non plus